[Music]
you're listening to a very special
quarantine midweek episode of life is
short i'm your host justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
with me as always in quarantine and
outside of quarantine oftentimes with me
outside but always with me inside
christian what a smooth opening what a
great introduction
we're not always together in quarantine
like we go to
that's true we
shower separately we sleep separately
thankfully yeah thanks for although
we've slept in the same bed before on
like road trips and stuff of course yeah
brothers um
and you know i i in the last couple of
years have become a very sensitive
sleeper so i've been wearing earplugs me
too you don't both have to wear earplugs
become sensitive sleepers as you get
older i wonder why that happened i used
to be now i think i know me too now i
need to wear an eye mask and
either
uh and either ear plugs or
um
an app like a like a sound like rain
sound oh i tried that for a while yeah
i've been doing that lately i don't like
shoving things in my ears i know but
it's the only way i can do it now even
though it's where we live now is really
quiet but you know the birds wake me up
like we got old
god damn when did that happen um all
right we have a lot to discuss today and
we're going to try to keep it short
first thing is that we are
no longer unfortunately able to do these
ad-free uh basically we want to keep our
advertisers happy because they make the
show work and make the show go yeah so
we are confronted with an option
a
don't do any of these quarantine
episodes or b
add an ad
into the quarantine episodes and we
really enjoy doing these and we're also
selfishly a little bored while in
quarantine so
we want to keep doing them
but unfortunately we have to um sneak it
ahead but maybe not unfortunately
because we're going to be doing ads for
companies that we like
also to offset the um us doing an ad
every week we thought it would be a good
idea to do
um a pro bono ad for a local
small business so
um if you guys want to write in
and
nominate a small business in your
hometown would you say describe why you
like it and what right you're doing
during the quarantine and how they're
maybe they're making deliveries and uh
we would love to do an ad for them so
yes uh so we want to start yeah right
start we'll start because um we don't
have any suggestions yet from you guys
we're gonna start with an ad of our own
uh one of our favorite local restaurants
so we're in um fairfield connecticut
area
and one of our favorite places is a
vietnamese restaurant that's relatively
new it's called
now i know it's pronounced fa
right but i i feel really pretentious i
think we've discussed this on the show i
feel very pretentious saying that it's
go so i'm going to say it's called fo na
trang trang well i can i didn't
pronounce any of those words correctly i
don't think uh so it's photo fo and nha
and then the third word is t-r-a-n-g
they're just a great v christian i love
vietnamese food i've uh they have great
pho or foe depending on what you're
comfortable saying now for the record
father record
the
the the right weight is the correct way
of saying it the proper pronunciation is
yeah but i feel douchey saying i foul do
she because
for years it was people thought like
felt cool that they knew the correct i
know like hipsters knew the correct way
of pronouncing pho and then and once you
know the correct way you like overdo it
yeah i found that a lot so i haven't
gone past that i recently i was at like
a little dinner party and
i mentioned this actually this
restaurant fo not trying uh because it
is new and we've been eating there a lot
it's genuinely so good so if you're in
the fairfield area check them out or
check them out their website is
phonetrong.com
yeah and uh that's that has a nice ring
to it and they're on the post road uh
and their number is 475-999-8433
call them up now the food is great and
as importantly i would say they're very
safe in their takeout orders and
extremely sweet kind people they really
are yeah they could use a little boost
right now so check them out and uh again
as christian said write in with any any
local businesses you like and we can
highlight those as we uh pay the piper
as well so ads are coming in this one
but we'll try to keep them fun as we
uh as we try i always try to do um
we we have a few things to talk about
i'm just texting with cherry o'connell
now because we were hoping to get a uh
check in on him and our friend anna
faris should we call ana now
sure all right let's try anna now see if
uh see how she's doing we'll check in
with our friend friend oh the show i
might pee at some point during this
conversation sure but just so you know
how long have you i'm not quitting the
show okay if i leave you reach the
voicemail you're gonna have to hold it
all right let's try jerry you want to
pee first uh no i'll hold it through
jerry okay okay
it could be long you know
we're going to cut them off if it's too
long
i don't think i'll pick up
so yesterday jerry and i um
were called out in a really positive way
by leslie jordan hello yo
yo
what's that noise
uh i'm i'm outside i'm on a street i had
to pick my uh car to be uh
it sounds like a drone are you near a
drone or a
no it's um it's a couple of uh people a
leaf blower
yeah oh uh so you're walking yeah i have
to walk home i left my car
i'm too afraid to take an uber because
what if i get the coven from the uber oh
yeah i wonder what's happening with uber
are they they must i saw a commercial
for uber they they're encouraging people
to not use the service can you guys tell
i'm wearing can you guys tell i'm
wearing uh a
bandana yeah i could hear it yeah it
sounds a little muffled
what what's the design what design do
you have
uh just a regular like one of those
western bananas it's blue in color
[Laughter]
um
i guess that would make me a
i look like a
you know jerry we're going to cut this
out because most mostly bloods listen to
our show
um
it's funny i did make a few and
blood jokes but no one really uh when
where
uh we went to the supermarket and my
wife was wearing a red bandana and i was
wearing a blue one
and i said um
and i said uh you know is there a
problem up in here and i acted like i
had a gun at my waist belt and my wife
had no idea what i was talking about oh
my god i just need to get arrested yeah
that's a dark bit
and then i started like making signs
with my fingers like like um
you know how like remember how gang
members yes i could never do them i
don't know if they still do it but they
still like they like scrunch up their
fingers it almost looks
it almost looks like
arthritic yeah yeah yes like it looks
like they have yeah like severe
arthritis but it's like messaging it's
gang messaging yeah and so i started
doing that to my wife and she was like
are you okay
you have joint problems
and um
what what uh
very well hey jerry i just thought um
there must not be any paparaz that's got
to be a bonus for all this the paparazzi
are probably gone uh you know i did get
paparazzi the other day and of course
yeah of course it was i went for a jog
and of course it was the one time i
didn't bring my mask and of course the
guy was like where's your mask oh really
he was shaming you as he was uh taking
your baby and took my photo oh god
well you know now i'm noticing
everyone's got a mask but like a week
ago that's how quickly things are
changing with this thing like it's a
week ago it was like maybe half the
people were wearing masks but now where
i live at where we live it's an order
it's been an ordinance
yeah i think it's
i think it's um
i think it's the law you know i think so
wait jerry what what happened to your
car um
i grounded it out man i mean i went up
uh
i went over a bump a little too fast
and it messed my uh
it messed my my muffler up oh oh like a
road bump like a speed bump yeah instead
of taking it to the dealership i take it
to like a like a muffler place deep in
the valley where i live and it's like uh
how long a walk back is that
it's gonna be about an hour and a half i
think what
what
can your wife pick you up yeah
you know i sent her a message i haven't
heard back yet and then i got your
message about calling in
oh so you're like kind of eager to do
this
well i have nothing else to do right
that's what i mean
my kids are like doing home school how's
homeschooling going
um they seem to really like it i don't
want to uh
oh god i don't want to generalize yeah
or anything but uh i don't know how you
guys are as students i know
i
i know justin was really into frogs but
um
my kids um
my kids really eagerly go to home school
every day which amazes me because
i try to put myself i try to put myself
in their position and i would have never
turned on my computer and started it i
know but think of it hold on a second
hitting the crosswalk thing with my
elbow yeah
yeah i got it
got it and what happened okay
um
oh i hear it beep beep the crosswalk uh
well jerry your parents were very
different people than you and rebecca
i'm sure it's a lot more fun to go
homeschooling with you and rebecca than
it is
no offense to your parents they're
wonderful people but they're probably
not as fun as you guys
um
i don't really have a lot to do with
their homeschooling i mean they're doing
long division now which i just found out
this morning i have no i mean i have no
idea what it is so rebecca does all that
uh rebecca doesn't do any of it either i
mean i pulled up my i pulled out my
phone to start punching numbers in there
and my kids immediately started yelling
at me and said you can't do that and i
was
trying to ask them why and they said
because we're not allowed to use
calculators and i was like
you know this is crazy and then they
said we have to show our work and i was
like
that makes sense
chris hey guys hold on a second this is
my wife oh okay all right we'll call you
back okay we'll call you back
we'll call you back okay
okay
just to set it up in case uh jerry calls
back oh he'll call back
all right he's got an hour and a half
walk ahead of him for when jerry calls
right um
i don't know if if you follow leslie
jordan he's a very fun person to follow
on instagram he's he's a really funny
actor um sweet person but very very
southern and um oh here's jay very
quickly calling back hey
jared
hey guys sorry about that hey but yeah
so rebecca's coming
rebecca's gonna come and pick me up oh
great are you just gonna wait on the
side of the road
no i'm gonna walk a little bit i mean i
have a full bandana it's a nice day in
l.a shirt is off i look good i'll send
you a photo you can put it up on the
website
that'd be great your whole you're
topless
yeah man wow it's it's about it's about
85 yeah
that's nice that does sound nice um
christian i might have to go out there
so i'll let you know if we do we might
have to go out there for a little bit um
just like
just like be safe you know what i'm
saying oh yeah good advice we had it
yeah we already had it you know we think
we have to get tested
oh i got the immunity test oh you did
yeah you know i was in new york until
march 16th am i just screaming through
this bandana or no
no
it sounds um
i got uh
you know i was in new york until the
16th of march he is talking louder are
you guys yelling at me about the yelling
are you guys laughing at me no it just
it's funny it sounds like you're yelling
i just hear you giggling i just hear you
giggling well well because your voice is
the quality of be of yelling but it's
not loud it's not loud it's really funny
you're like this you're kind of like
that
i just heard i just heard justin
snickering and it's just it's just
uncool to invite people out sorry
all right sorry sorry it's just i mean i
don't know
i don't know how they do it on armchair
expert or anything but i mean
wait cheers that those guys laugh you're
right you're right you're right i'm
sorry now you sound like that paparazzi
you're shaming me uh hey so you were i
know you were in new york to the 16. i
was in new york until the 16th and i
actually interacted with people who
publicly tested positively oh right i
and um
i thought for sure i had it but i had no
symptoms so i wasn't going to go get
tested because they were saying only go
get you have symptoms and all that stuff
and
but i mean i didn't see anybody
but then our pediatrician
um
emailed us and said she is doing a test
survey for the school district
did uh she only has the antibody test
mm-hmm
and um
wow i emailed her and i said listen um
i was in new york until the 16th and she
said come in oh wow we got to take that
and
i found out about 10 minutes later i did
not have the antibody i was so bummed
out oh that is about i'm sure we have it
i'm sure we have it too but it wouldn't
be great to know for sure for sure it
was
what was the best place
they pricked your finger they took a
little blood and then you sit there for
10 minutes next to people in bend and
masks and stuff it's pretty freaky
um
but um i was a little i gotta tell you
it was emotionally it was weird for me i
was a little bummed that i did not have
it no i bet i bet because you want to
kind of almost like you want to get it
over with you want to know that it's
something that you already went through
i'm hoping we had it i'm pretty sure we
did but um
jerry and i don't know how to pivot from
here but how how's the saxophone playing
everyone wants to know
oh um
it's not it's it's
it's not that great you haven't made
progress
you know it just it sits there i have a
little like desk area next to um
oh gosh like we've sort of run out of
room so there's a little bathtub and
next to the bathtub i have a little desk
area and it just sits there
it's a bummer i haven't really touched
it you know it's funny another friend of
mine on instagram she started playing
she's playing the trumpet
because we were talking last week what
uh christian i both admire that you even
had the gumption to do that i think it's
a cool thing
but yeah i just
i just rented it i mean it's kind of fun
hey um speaking of uh fun
how do you know leslie jordan because we
were last night jerry and i were both
mentioned unless leslie mentioned us in
a very flattering instagram post and
leslie we're gonna have leslie on as the
guest this week
so is there anything you want you want
to ask him or or uh um no i've i've i've
worked with leslie a number of times
yeah he uh
oh i just love jerry
he's a frequent guest star on all
television shows yeah he is
such a great actor he's been doing it
forever um you know
justin if if i were you interviewing him
i would start to get into stories of his
career
and how
long it's been i mean he's been doing
this since
i think he's been la since the 60s uh 82
82 but he had some great stories we
already did it jared we did the
interview oh but it was really good i
said i didn't know that you you knew him
until that instagram post uh where we
should play it actually it's really fun
we'll play when we get off with you um
but uh i was i was like very flattered
by that
yeah it was really nice of him yeah it
was uh straight boys there's a lot of
straight boys out there yeah and you too
like you're 40 of his favorite straight
boys that's pretty cool that's pretty
cool i love i just love how you know
the choir and instagram has made him
i mean a sensation oh no god three i
know i remember a couple weeks ago
uh my max greenfield said you gotta
follow this guy you gotta follow leslie
another
straight boy who was mentioned by by
leslie uh
it's it's just awesome because i mean
here's a guy who's been
very successful in entertainment for so
long you know i wouldn't say that
stardom
i wouldn't say that stardom has eluded
him
i mean it's super rude justin coming in
with the 40s joke well you just said the
60s i know but it was super rude i mean
it's just crazy this is not
this is not what dax does you know what
i'm saying
yeah but you know you're my friend and
we like to tease each other i understand
that but i i you know this is like
this is like for air i'm assuming you
guys are recording oh we haven't started
yet
oh oh well i didn't know no i'm kidding
we've been recording
um i know that just always
always abr with you always be recorded
uh well we're waiting for content we
love you and uh thanks for hold on a
second no no i have another like i got
another 15 minutes 15 minutes the show's
not like it's a checking episode
um
we're not
oh what else is going on no no if you
don't have anything hold on a second i
saw you guys are baking stuff you guys
are cooking oh yeah i made a chicken pot
pie i've been cooking it was delicious
wasn't it great it really was oh my god
jerry i've been following the new york
times cooking recipes
uh yeah oh chicken pop i was amazing i
never made one i've been cooking a lot
you're turning into quite the housewife
yeah
thanks who does most the cooking in your
house
oh i would say
rebecca does that i will say the choir
combat has really made her
an amazing
chef
yeah oh good you know my wife i love her
beautiful amazing mom we have such a fun
time i mean like my soulmate yeah
um
but
yeah there's a bud coming
sometimes better get this out before she
picks you up
sometimes the experimenting in the
kitchen was
was experimenting my wife always took
big swings
and you know sometimes
oh gosh what's a memorable swing in a
missed dish that she she made
oh god it usually involved like
something creamy rich and creamy
like a chicken
a creamy
something like maybe like something
involving like a bernays and it was like
but it was also like a healthy bernese
made with
almond flour yeah there was always like
a catch
right yeah that's extreme yeah it's like
cream based but without the dairy cream
base but no dairy made with cashews
with cashew milk and it was like oh gosh
no no no no yeah
and it would like it would it would be a
little frightening and i mean here's the
worst part and this is the part i may
ask you to cut out
it would sometimes be a little
physically upsetting you know what i'm
saying yeah
well like it would
it would cause the body wasn't used to
digesting yeah the body would just be
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
yeah
this isn't like cream of broccoli soup
this is cactus pus like totally
different
yeah
and
but i will say during the choir my wife
has really stepped it up it's really i i
notice how you keep referring to it as
the car really casually uh is that
something you just recently picked up in
your
like workshopping
no it's been
i've seen it on social media oh really
yeah i guess i yeah at the choir
um oh i oh you did you just send a
picture yeah christian showing me the
picture you just said
i wish this is when i wish the show were
uh could be televised oh jerry you're
ripped you look good you have a yeah
that's a i would call that a very
traditional band hold on hold on one
once okay we're gonna have to go
okay we love you
um
okay i just hang up
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wandery plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
all right so now we are going to call as
we uh
as we do we're going to call our friend
dave
dr dave dr dave that's right i forgot
the name that i get and he never went by
dr dave
but now he does
isn't that funny that like
you know people listen to this and uh
and now a lot of people think of him as
doctor dave even though whether you like
it or not you're not dr dave yeah
i don't know if we have that kind of
influence force that nickname on well
as far as some people know dr dave
hey how's it going
uh has anyone ever called you dr dave
um
i mean you know not so much occasionally
yeah um well we were just laughing at
how now you're
i don't for whatever reason we keep
calling you dr dave it just has a nice
ring to it and now that's after 40
something years on the planet that's now
your uh name to some people
um how you doing
um okay how are you guys holding up
pretty good good yeah yeah i hate saying
that um especially to a health care
worker on the front lines but um
obviously are not a care in the world
yeah our view is very limited what but
you're right there what's um
any updates you can give us about how
it's going um oh hang on my my
daughter's walking in the room right
over here
i'm on the call oh my goodness you're
bleeding well welcome to life at home
come here she's going to be on the phone
while we talk
you know actually it brings up that that
brings up what i want to talk about yeah
work-life balance i actually want to
talk about um
you know in pediatrics but really for
for all specialties now people are
talking about this sort of second wave
of non-coveted related issues yes and um
you know well my daughter has a little
skin knuckle here we'll take care of
that in a second
but
this one's four
i got three three amazing strong
wonderful
wonderful girls how does she skin her
knee
uh it's her finger i don't know we
haven't asked her yet do you uh dear how
did you skin your finger i was
scratching it
she was scratching it why were you
scratching it you know you're in my ear
so she can't hear you oh uh which is how
i like to keep it usually the
the podcast of the daddy only that makes
sense that makes it you know clean it up
justin um but
we'll have a family episode okay so but
but you know but but actually you know
so it's been what around six weeks i'm
losing track of time but you know um so
think about all those uh you know
primary care issues there's maintenance
things people with chronic illnesses but
also like a lot of what we're seeing in
pediatrics is new onset diabetes um
appendicitis you know diseases that sort
of you know they'll come at any time
they don't care whether it's covet
season or not and yeah we're seeing
unfortunately late presentations so
normally someone might come in you know
lower threshold to come in types of
things right but now they're waiting for
the last minute
yeah so we've i mean there's been other
articles about it but we're even talking
locally like how can we go actually do
outreach in our communities um
especially you know areas where there's
less access to care or yeah how can
and so to go out there and say you know
we're open for business we want you to
come in for this yeah and teach about
what is appropriate to come in and this
is the protocol for if you do have to
come in for something exactly exactly
because
you know and different you know
obviously people different um
levels of access to care and different
you know levels of education and stuff
so it's just a really important topic
yeah to educate everyone about on a much
less important but um
still
something that i'm selfishly concerned
with
oh what'd she say
you have blood on your mouth because i
just kissed her her hand
but sorry back to you
no
i'm just gonna say how tragic it is that
theaters are closing um
no dave you wanna do you wanna we can
call you back you wanna take care of um
it sounds like you're nothing comes
before my children but this is actually
a good lesson for her and resiliency so
okay you know so you believe me yeah our
mother
uh and dave i wanted to ask you about um
the risks of because you know one of the
big stories this week is uh certain
states reopening and perhaps reopening
you know opening prematurely so
scientifically speaking if these um
if these states open prematurely what
what might the effect be on the
on the state of the s well popular first
of all we don't know because they're not
testing
you know i i need to see a plan that has
universal testing and screening because
if you're not tracking this thing
you're not going to know and look
they're accusing new york of padding
numbers because they're looking at
statistics and saying oh my goodness
there's x percent more depth deaths you
know than there normally are in april
and you know it'd be prudent to realize
that that's probably from people dying
at home due to covet who didn't come in
and they're absolutely right you know
within a margin of error you can't be
precise but you should be counting it to
make it political and say you're padding
well you know how to get rid of that
argument let's test everyone right let's
really look at the numbers and then as
we go forward because we need to be able
to this isn't going away you know we
need to open safely and part of doing
that is being able to track track
outbreaks track hot spots this is basic
epidemiology well speaking of that dave
how are we keep hearing about all these
tests antibody testing um i follow ali
wentworth on instagram her husband is
george stephanopoulos and he posted a
thing where he just got tested
and he's donating his his plasma
how do we do that how does everyone when
are those tests going to be readily
available do you have any ideas um so i
think i think uh someone just listening
to a talk that there's i i'm not gonna
get the number right there was like 50
or 100 different tests in the market but
like as we've talked before not all are
great go with your your um
go with your most official places your
your academic universities or your like
the new york state blood center i think
has coordinated it so a lot of public
services are coordinating testing and
plasma banking and donation and stuff
like that so
um you know several of them are starting
are parts of studies like on
convalescent serum um
but um you know they're also
yeah so like i mean look quest
diagnostics i think has a test so there
are like i think my doctor just emailed
me today saying hey if you want this
test come get it now they probably have
a decent one there i have to look into
that one have you been tested
no i haven't been tested yet
my wife might get tested soon she's been
doing a lot of uh work on the floor and
her hospital has opened up the testing
more broadly so far we have it at ours i
kind of you know i'm fortunate that i
was not out very sick i had sort of a
mild thing early who knows what it was
i'd love to find out but
um but some of my colleagues who like i
know for sure got tested were positive
you know they're first in line to get it
as they should be and figure out you
know what their response is so so you
know i'll get it when it's not crowded
and i'm not taking anyone else's place
there's you know again from that
standpoint that kind of immunity testing
we still don't fully know what it means
right and everyone's you know have
individual
you know reasons for getting tested
but we just don't know how long that
immunity lasts and what it means you
know presumably if i'm asymptomatic and
i have the immunity i'm probably not
spreading it as much to people but we
just don't
really know enough about it yet that's
part of why it's being studied and at
what point do you think i mean this is
probably too
way too premature to know but
at what point do you think we will know
some of those answers like how long does
it take to do tests like that to to know
for sure about immunity and stuff like
that that's a good question i don't know
i mean i think that that like there's
lots of different there's variables this
is being sliced and diced right and
we're looking at it um i think that some
some questions we won't know for a year
right we won't know for example for
example one reason there's an influenza
there's an influenza vaccine every year
that's different right that's because
the flu itself you know mutate shifts
exactly so the immunity to one flu does
have some protection to next season
sometimes but not 100 and so it's a
moving target other vaccines as you know
sort of like one shot and you may be
covered for 10 years yeah tetanus
tetanus you know good reminder to
everyone out there is every 10 years you
know a lot of people ignore that after
their kids and don't get that shot and
polio is is polio just like a one-time
thing that was a one-time
polio there's well there's several
that's part of the series that you get
when you're younger yeah right as a baby
and toddler and then you're sort of set
um after that
but it's also it's also you know because
of like you know look at measles we
thought you know you have a vaccine
schedule we think you're set but there
was also because of herd immunity and
very low prevalence of measles this is
one of those contagious diseases out
there yeah um and uh you know even more
so than this to some degree it just
burns out sooner because of its
contagiousness and um you know so during
those outbreaks people who are adults
who have been vaccinated found out hey
they're immunity waned and now they were
susceptible and they got measles so so
immune immunity is um
it's a tricky science right there's a
lot of aspects to it oh thanks dave i
know you have a lot i know you have a
lot going on now uh a lot to do and uh
you gotta get about your daughter who's
bleeding
[Laughter]
all right well adira can you say bye bye
bye adira
i know you can't hear me i don't know
do you want to plug the show do you want
to say life is short
no she doesn't have a shot yeah
you have to set up a contract with her
uh that makes sense that you almost get
her agent in touch with your agent you
know that makes sense we almost got a
free plug
thanks
thanks buddy uh thanks for taking the
time as always and uh forever of course
we'll we'll check in next week
all right sounds good take care of you
thanks
thanks buddy bye-bye that's really
interesting um
right now let's get into some
some topics okay oh i don't know jerry's
calling back no no no no no no no no i'm
just gonna say we gotta go okay hey hey
chair let me call you back uh we gotta
wrap the show out
hey justin i'm in the car with everybody
[Music]
rebecca
everybody says hi hey
wait are the kids there charlie and
dolly yeah
say hi to justin hi justin hi charlie
i miss you guys
all right guys we we miss you too all
right all right stay safe
oh
sweet
aren't you glad you picked up now yeah i
really am i'm glad i encourage you to
pick up
um okay well because we have a few
things on the docket that and we do want
to try to keep this
show short
it's hard with jerry
uh well she came to pick him up pretty
quick
i can't believe he's going to walk home
an hour and a half although
good exercise uh okay
what do we got what do we got what do we
got we have um a few things oh you know
about uh this derek jeter thing we
should let's put this to bed really okay
yeah um christian got somebody wrote in
about if you've been listening to the
show you know uh christian made the
he made the claim that there is a chance
he could hit better with his dominant
hand than derek jeter can with his
lesser hand
let me let me say that again there is a
chance that he could
and uh somebody wrote wrote in they had
proposed that to their boyfriend who i
guess knows a lot about baseball yeah so
someone sent in this letter and they
included a little audio clip
um and you'll see what i mean in a
second so uh
let me just read it really fast dear
justin christian i'm a day one shorty
listener and love tuning in each week to
your podcast i usually travel for work
and end up binging my podcast when i'm
back in town given the current state of
the world and being quarantined i'm
currently binging life is short and just
finished barbara corcoran's episode was
very entertaining at the end of the barb
c episode i couldn't help but laugh at
the fan that wrote in about her
boyfriend chiming in about the christian
derek jeter lefty debacle my boyfriend
andrew is a huge baseball fan and an
even bigger yankees fan side note i also
made him listen to neil degrasse tyson
episode it was amazing he loved it after
listening to christian's feedback and
laughing in general about how fans were
getting involved i had to join in myself
minutes after finishing the episode i
went to my boyfriend's house and
announced to him and his roommate that
quote i have a very important sports
related question which by the way i like
i like that she's like bringing a
a point up to to her boyfriend and his
friend and like the show
motivated her to do that i like that too
yeah and i'm going to ask you live and
record your responses they of course
heard the word sports and were
immediately in since they are having
withdrawals of all sports during
quarantine i use the voice memo on my
phone and recorded my question and the
response is c attached okay um so this
uh this is from
meg megan or megan it's with an a right
yeah i've never seen that spelling g
m-a-g-a-n maggie magon magan
matt megan from jacksonville
jacksonville jacksonville florida okay
so here is
the uh audio
life is short recording justin long
you've actually heard it a little bit um
there is kind of a co-host who is his
brother his name is christian and
christian likes to say on the podcast
that
he i'd like to say
no hold on she got it all wrong
this guy is saying that he can hit
better left then derek jeter can hit
better left because derek is a
right-handed no pitcher i mean
right-handed hitter
so what are your thoughts on that no it
could you could be like very nice oh you
did it
no
i don't think so why i do not why do you
think that right darren teeter is a
all-time baseball player and one of the
best of all time probably very
coordinated with it
and i'm sure
derek jeter even around hitting
lefty right i agree yeah
[Music]
i don't know
i would have to know what christian long
does that's fair um he is a co-host on a
podcast right now he is justin long's
brother and i think he does some acting
but we can fact check it when i send
this to them he's not a baseball player
okay
okay thanks for your participation
ah thanks megan okay thank you very much
i like that i do too she for the record
she
mangles the question her boyfriend must
have and the friend must have been like
uh
they must be like that guy must be out
of his mind what is this podcast
he's making these wild claims so so here
is here was my original write better
poetry than walt whitman it's very
simple it's
can is there a chance
that i christian
can hit better as a right-handed hitter
which is my dominant side then derek
jeter can hit left-handed which is not
his dominate dominant side of course
there's a chance
i don't for the record i don't think
there is a good chance of it i think
there's a horrible chance of it in fact
if i had to bet my own money on
if derek jeter is a better lefty hitter
than i'm a righty hitter i would
definitely put money on derek jeter
being a better lefty oh i put all my
money on it see i don't know about all
my money why because and my only point
is
that he might be really inept doing
anything from his left side but i do i
do agree with these guys that because
he's an all-time great baseball player
he doesn't even have to be he could just
be a baseball player professionally but
he happens to be an all-time great one i
think yeah he could be on the savannah
his even if he has even if he's bad at
hitting from his left side the fact that
his hand-eye coordination must be so
incredible
he could probably around and do
better than i can for my right i'm sure
i was just saying it was the
hypothetical wasn't about my abilities
as a baseball player or his abilities
right it was more about left versus
right dominance okay magon that's it but
for the record of course i think there's
a much better chance that he he can hit
lefty better than i can write he's much
better isn't it weird to hear uh
strangers two people
say your guys say your name in such like
an incredulous with like a hint of uh
not hostility but just like there's
there's some kind of judgment it is
weird behind it what does christian long
do yeah oh he's he's uh on a podcast
sometimes uh no he can't do as well as
derek jeter but well guess what they're
right if someone posed that same
question to me i would be i wouldn't
even take the time to answer i would say
oh he he needs to get he needs to seek
help
right he needs to talk to somebody you
should talk to a therapist you know it's
a little bit like that um that scene in
the simpsons episode where monty burns
gets all the ringers for the nuclear
softball team and somebody comes up to
their oh homer goes up to uh darryl
strawberry and he goes you're dear
strawberry and he's yes
you play right field he goes yes
i play right field he goes okay
are you better than me if strawberry
goes well i don't know you but yes
[Laughter]
uh speaking of great athletes how's this
for a segway
um
you all need to watch even if you're not
a basketball fan uh i hope everyone's
watching the michael jordan documentary
because that was a highlight of our
yeah let's do a couple of wrecks some
quarantine rex okay well that's number
one number one it's called the last
dance i'm sure you've most of you have
seen it it's really good good i was so
upset there were two episodes on last
sunday and and the new one is two two
more coming this sunday nine p.m eastern
i will say though
the buzz
before that came out was all about
how michael jordan was this tyrannical
crazy teammate it's like you're going to
see michael you're going to think of
michael jordan in a month you're going
to think he's a horrible person and yeah
i got to say
after the first two episodes i don't
see him that way but that's only been
two episodes i know there's a lot left
to go and um you know i think
he's just an alpha male that's what he
he's not a bad person he is he is just
the ultimate alpha yes yeah he demands
perfection and and it's hard to like
argue with that because he himself was
so
was perfect i mean i wouldn't want to be
friends with him or on a team with them
i definitely
i know i'm not suggesting
that i should be for the record
uh yeah
you you i just had a visual of you being
on the uh look at the 1997. john paxton
jackson paxton's so much bigger than you
of course doesn't he don't start a new
sports controversy well i don't know
christian long but
um
uh another thing we should recommend
yeah
uh
the new bachelor series yes listen to
your heart it's called listen to your
heart it is it fuses really good
uh it's like bachelor in paradise mixed
with
american idol i'd say yeah and is that
fair to say yeah that's pretty good and
um i would also add that they are a lot
better at being they're much more
presentational they're better at being
presentational than most bachelor and
bachelorettes are i think because
a they're performers they're like that's
this is what they aspire to do
they want to be
professional musicians i think
yeah and b i think now i something
occurred to me that um i think everyone
who is in that entertainment field
influence or whatever it is i think
everyone is becoming i don't want to use
the word better but they're becoming
more uh accustomed to being on camera
because with stories and instagram and
tick tock
they're just constantly
on camera yeah they're filming
themselves so i i also i think they're
more at ease the most fun part of the
regular bachelor series is for for us
anyway i would say
is um
seeing the contestants trying to become
famous yes
more than seeing them get caught up more
than seeing them trying to find love
because let's face it the bachelor has
turned into that yeah it's turned into
people trying to
be known and get bigger instagram
followings and all that but this very
rarely we've talked about very rarely is
it pure i mean it was in the beginning
it was yeah but is it ever like a pure
pursuit of love but see i think this
show in a way is like a better version
of the bachelor because these people are
the stakes are higher for them in terms
of being famous so
not only do they just want to be known
as people like the regular contestants
do but they also want to be respected as
musicians so so you conflate the two oh
yeah so so their desire to find
themselves in a romantic relationship is
so strong because it means that their
music will be heard yes yes it's
brilliant it really is it's brilliant
and sometimes they'll just bust out a
song
you know out of out of nowhere yeah if
one sense that that he or that he's he
or she is by the shopping block they'll
like say goodbye to someone and bring
their guitar you know
sneak in a song yeah um i just wanted to
uh have a quick chat with you before we
do that
so i've been thinking
oh it's really funny uh and one more
recommendation is that netflix show yeah
but i have to say and i've been thinking
about it we saw the first episode and
it's called too hot to handle
and um it's it's kind of too hot for me
to handle yes you know both of these two
watch handles too hard to handle
literally um not literally uh it's just
so filthy it's too much it's it's like
it made me feel um
sad almost you know after they're just
they're so
such narcissists i mean
that they're they seem so
corrupt and like
they're rotten well they also seem like
they have real problems with the dick
like sex addiction yeah yeah so they
it's hard to laugh it is it's hard to
find that funny or enjoyable i i saw the
first it's like sad and
borderline grotesque i think yes it's
but kind of fun
if you have a high threshold for that
stuff and if you're like us and you are
feeling the need for if you if you're
missing the bachelor and you just want
to fill that
that fill your cup yeah yeah
your cup will runneth over with trashy
reality uh moments because it it really
it takes whatever the bachelor
whatever trash the bachelor offered it
takes it to a whole other level agreed
um one that i think is it's just too
much for me but you guys might have a
higher threshold
um
now we posed this question to the
listeners last time um
what would you rather
do a or b
um what was the last week i forget oh i
remember uh
skip oh yeah yeah oh we got some funny
feedback or uh we're a propeller beanie
all the time we did get some funny
feedback
oh and you know you know what's really
fun actually maybe we want to encourage
people to do like megan did uh is to if
you want to record your friends yeah
talking about that yeah talking about
questions or not whatever it's fun to
play little audio clips it is
um so
we we got a few good ones sent in
this week uh some funny would you rather
let's get the ball rolling yeah i
haven't had these so well this is this
is one we just did the other day all
right uh and the question was oh this
i've heard would you rather for a would
you rather a
never cut
wax or treat in any way never any remove
and remove
easier way of saying it thank you
any hair on your body including your
head anywhere in your body for the rest
of your life uh-huh or
lose your sense of smell and taste okay
that is such a good question
we had a hard time with this i
i still am not certain of my answer but
i said um i would rather the hair option
i would i would rather keep all my hair
i think i would too it it's just
too
i think at a certain point you would
have to just accept that you look like
an old wizard
because that's what you'll look like
eventually i just think i think food is
is
such a pleasure that i would i wouldn't
want to live without and that's been it
would be disgusting i you'd have to
learn to get like like what um uh tie it
back what sikhs do yes yeah you'd have
to just
adopt seek practices i'd have to you
know seek out the best ways i knew
you're gonna yeah you saw me yeah
uh you saw me seeking for um
yeah especially with the mouth see guys
it's different because
if yeah now i'm imagining eating getting
to enjoy food but then you have all this
like hair that's dripping into i don't
know how zz top did it zz top kept that
look going i think they still have one
of them anyway still has that crazy
beard
i can't imagine going through life with
one of those things yeah voluntarily
yeah it's not even hypothetical
all right let us okay so uh people wrote
in with some hype they did i haven't
read them properly yet but let's see um
okay uh
this is from megan s
spelled uh regularly
yeah
m-e-g-a-n justin christian hello not
with an h hello that always gave me
trouble hello all the way from budapest
here's my hypothetical for you
which would you rather
listen to the same song for the rest of
your life
or
watch the same movie it could be any
movie or song but that would be it until
the day you die i hope you guys are
doing well love your show megan megan
it's easy for me wait wait wait don't
tell me um
so you can only listen to this one song
and no other music right
wow
so movie or song wow all right on the
count of three one two three movie oh
wow
easy really i i'd only listened to the
same song you listen you'd watch the
same movie you'd have to
really i see i think i prefer in general
movies
to to i mean that'd be hard to only hear
one song
yeah and it would drive away i think i
misunderstood the question she's saying
would you only listen to one song you
can only listen to if i think as far as
i understand you only oh one song
or you can only watch one movie uh oh i
i didn't i didn't oh maybe i'm wrong
wait read it again
which would you rather listen to the
same song for the rest of your life
right let's say it's uh norwegian wood
or watch the same movie
tootsie let's say
it could be any movie or song but that
would be it until the day you died oh oh
oh oh
um both would suck
i would
i would pick the same
song because i want to watch can you
hear me songs in movies that's what i
was going to say yeah that's why my gut
was pick a movie because then you get
some music in there too yeah that's not
really fair
uh i would i i don't wanna i would
rather have a variety of movies i think
than i don't wanna i don't wanna shame
her question but i want and i'm not even
shaming it but i would like to ask megan
if um in those movies you can listen to
you'd have to it's part of the game of
course yeah
uh that's right
let's try another that's a tough one um
okay from brittany
no britney b
uh would you rather climb a mountain of
maggots
eat a bowl of scabs oh my or swim
or swim in a river of snot
okay wait wait wait wait okay
eat climb climb a mountain of magic
mountain how big a mountain i don't know
she doesn't say climb a mountain of
maggots eat a bowl of scabs or swim in a
river if it's not my my first question
questions who's scabs and who's not and
how much
and how long how long would you have to
swim for
i would imagine the same amount of time
for all of these things let's say okay
i'd rather swim in the snot river i
think
and in climbing the mountain of maggots
can you wear clothing that properly
protects yourself and if so i would
definitely do that oh and and will you
be able to get leverage with the maggots
i mean they're slippery slippery yeah i
would have made what do you think of
when you think of maggots i think of one
thing immediately nothing oh really i
don't think of one thing immediately oh
i go right to that scene in lost boys
when uh i haven't seen that since i was
a little oh my that was such a
formative scene in my uh
when i because i guess i saw it during a
formative time if it was a rice do you
remember that i don't remember okay if
it was a river of my own snot i would do
that oh yeah for sure
what about your don't be so excited
about it
what about your own scabs that would be
my second one and then the maggots i
don't want to and also
it would be gross it's weird that when i
i had the most uh visceral reaction to
the scab
part
i got i got the most nauseous when when
i thought of that so
i guess that would eliminate that i
guess i did i'd probably take them out
you know both have to climb the mountain
to magnets all right let's do one more
yeah
uh hi christian justin my boyfriend and
brittany that was disgusting
my boyfriend and i are at odds with this
would you rather okay so it's would you
rather be in an olympic sized swimming
pool with a great white
shark wow that you can't see
what or
walk through the same sized sea of a
forest with a grizzly bear
uh i would do the forest
yeah
i just have more confidence how long
confidence in my running abilities than
my swimming pool okay wait wait so you
have to you'd have to swim the length of
the pool
uh
length of the floor says would you
rather be in an olympic-sized swimming
pool it's like
[Music]
i would rather avoid yeah you'd be able
to see the death on my feet than in
water i i would too i think i'm more
comfortable on land
in fact i know i am
wait so would you be able to but i've
heard with sharks
one first of all if you're not splashing
around no
i'm saying you might have a better
chance against the shark if you
i i i've seen so many of those shark
same with a bear though that you go for
no no with a shark you just go for its
eyes you just like gouge it it's i
oh but with a bear it lets you stand up
straight oh my god i'm picturing this
christian's doing it he's doing it for
me if you stand up straight and what and
just like puff your chest out oh my god
and not threaten them but also not run
away you can't do that in the forest if
you have to traverse the length of the
forest traverse
um i just don't know what that
what the goal is like how if it's a time
thing all right let i'd rather avoid the
bear i would too uh we also wonder who
would want also just the just
the fear i'm picturing being in oh my
god being in a pool with that you can't
see like a murky pool with a
great white maybe and the bear you could
see it'd be scary but you'd be able to
i know you're preaching to the choir i
picked the bear too uh we also wondered
who would win in a fight
winning a fight a grizzly bear or a
silverback gorilla oh i think a gorilla
might win
i have no idea yeah how do you know i
don't well i i think gorillas are the
most powerful animals on the planet i
think
you know what gorilla can take a um a
coconut and with its arm outstretched
and just uh squeeze it and smash it with
its one hand whoa by squeezing it it's
pretty cool and speaking of not eating a
lot of meat
they only eat vegetables
i knew that i heard that uh p.s i'm
always waiting for someone to say janice
when you ask who their favorite muff
muppet is oh like wow
someone said that at some point i think
somebody did wait there was a janice uh
was it anna autoferris seems like a
janice guys maybe i just uh uh did what
happened to pass the time during
quarantine i i joined tik tok which i
was so against at first but now i spend
so much time on hopefully it's just a
phase my username is mir kunzi b i don't
have tic tac tic talk and instagram i
don't either i i i probably shouldn't
say this because i said this about
instagram i'm not gonna get it but um
i i the reason i'm probably not gonna
get tick tock is because i just know i
would i waste so much time on it that
great especially now um speaking of
things we said we wouldn't do and now
we're going to do uh instagram i do want
to play that the leslie jordan only
because we referenced it and
so last night
leslie posted remember oh yeah okay
i had a red letter today yesterday i got
interviewed twice
by a podcast justin long long adorable
straight boy
and then jason kennedy who's for e
something another
on instagram precious adorable straight
boy
i love straight boys that could care
less who's gay or not they're just out
to have a good time that's me i'm gonna
make a list of straight boys i love
number one
justin long number two jason kennedy
that's like winning in australia oh my
god i was so max greenfield
number four
um
jerry o'connell
so friends of the show friends of the
show yeah so that's why jerry and i had
a little uh we had a laugh about that
and and we're both i think very
flattered and leslie is our guest this
coming tuesday yes i can't wait leslie
is the best has such
not only does he have a great actual
voice but um
he has such a great spirit such a
a wonderful
playful quality and i've he's been
bringing me so much joy during this time
as i know he has been with a lot of
people he's up to he's got millions of
followers now on instagram so we're
going to talk to leslie uh uh this
tuesday uh and now like we always do we
will read a quarantine letter this is
from bob s subject is my quarantine
activity origami cranes hi justin
christian i discovered your podcast a
couple of weeks ago while listening to
business wars cool
i have enjoyed an ad not that but that's
great
i have enjoyed listening to your
interviews especially the one with your
grandma jody because my dad was born in
1905 and lived to be 102 wow
just a few months short of 103. wow your
grandma reminds me a lot of my dad with
a great sense of humor and a sharp mind
my dad was in a vaudeville oh cool he
was in vaudeville in the 1920s and
performed professionally as banjo buddy
wow you can actually find a couple of
his recordings on itunes i'm gonna
look for those
banjo buddy i that that whole world
fascinates me one of my favorite books
is charlie chaplin's autobiography he
talks about that
that uh world anyway uh i'm a 75 year
old man with many hobbies that are
keeping me busy while being sheltered at
home one of my hobbies is origami and a
couple of weeks ago i initiated a
mission i've named cranes conquering
covid19
my mission involves folding a thousand
origami cranes why because traditionally
was believed that if one folded a
thousand origami cranes one's wish would
come true i didn't know that i just
finished folding my 1000th crane so i
can now make wish and so i can now make
wish that the worldwide coveted pandemic
will run its course quickly and
successfully that's really nice bob um
the crane has a rich tradition the crane
has a rich tradition in some asian
cultures the crane is a mystical
creature and is believed to live for a
thousand years
it represents peace good health and
longevity and is sometimes referred to
as the bird of happiness the wings of
the crane were believed to carry souls
up to paradise i certainly hope these
wings have carried today's coronavirus
victims there
yes the crane has also become a symbol
of hope and healing during challenging
times such as those we are now enduring
listening to your interesting podcast
interviews while folding my origami
cranes has made the project much more
enjoyable oh maybe you're doing that
right now
this project took about 90 hours of my
time my original plan was to send these
origami cranes to local hospitals to be
given to patients as well as frontline
healthcare professionals however it
seems that hospitals are reluctant to
accept gifts from outside sources due to
potential health concerns makes sense so
now i am trying to decide what to do
with these 1 000 paper cranes any
suggestions you or your listeners might
have would be much appreciated um in the
meantime
yeah i would like one i know i know i
wonder how big they are
origami cranes i wonder that's cool
origami is really beautiful sorry to try
in the meantime this is back to bob uh
back to bob yeah in the meantime i will
continue to listen to your podcast while
undertaking other hobbies and projects
while being sheltered at home once our
sheltering and place orders are lifted
you will find me back on the golf course
which i miss terribly thanks bob s uh
thank you bob that is what a what a cool
way to pass the time an interesting cool
75 year old guy keeping busy i think you
know people ask our grandmother all the
time like what's your secret
uh they don't always say it with that
voice i don't know why i did that um
and i i think our grandmother said i
want to speak for her but she said
versions of this is that she's always
keeping busy she keeps herself very busy
on whether it's
just sheer curiosity about what's
happening in her condo complex or yeah
watching jeopardy or writing letters
she's always busy origami's always seems
so cool to me i know it's a beautiful
art i would like one of those cranes ah
that'd be great bob uh to get i wouldn't
mind you both wanted origami crane from
bob 90 hours it's amazing
yeah and what a great idea yeah that he
was gonna give it to hospitals um and
i'm also curious what bob's gonna do now
what's the next thing you know uh it
also makes me want to golf even though i
never have uh we've talked about this me
too yeah well maybe that's for the post
uh quarantine time so uh let us know how
you guys are
uh passing your time and if you are
working
outside of home then uh as always we are
deeply grateful and um certainly if
you're working in the healthcare
profession
we could not be more grateful so thank
you and thank you for listening and if
you have a fun hypothetical that you
want to throw our way we love discussing
them just very selfishly yeah we would
like to get them um what's another one
that we we had that we can oh we shared
the one about the body here yeah right
what do you think of the body here one
um
anyway life is short at
life wondery.com be a dream
and this has been life is short who
hosts yeah life is short is hosted by me
oh justin long and it's co-hosted and
produced by christian long and by megan
monaco senior producers michelle miesh
lans audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producers are
marshall
louie and hernan lopez
for wondering
[Music]
you